[موسيقى]
وهذه هي مشاهدينا صور مباشره من العاصمه
الفرنسيه باريس من التظاهره التي انطلقت
قبل ساعات خلال هذا النهار وكما يعني
نشاهد ما زالت الامنيه الموجوده وما زالت
التظاهره يعني
تستكمل بهذه الاثناء سانتقل الى باريس
ومراسل العربيه فادي الدهوك فادي كيف هي
صوره من هناك كم الاعداد التي شاركت بهذه
التظاهره وهل يعني من مواجهات دارت
بالساعات الماضيه
اهلا ليال حتى الان لم تصدر اي احصائيات
عن الجهه المنظمه لاعداد المتظاهرين لكن
السلطات الفرنسيه توقعت مشاركه نحو 850
الف شخص اليوم في عموم فرنسا هنا في باريس
الموكب كما ترون عبر الشاشه هو ضخم جدا
هناك عشرات الالاف الذين يتظاهرون اليوم
في العاصمه باريس احتجاجا على رفع او
مساعي الحكومه رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما
طبعا هذه التظاهره تاتي بالتزامن مع دراسه
مشروع القانون بين لجنتين
احداهما لمجلس الشيوخ والثانيه لمجلس
النواب اللجنتان تم التوافق او تم تم
التواصل الى نص توافقي بينهما لكن هذا
النص ايضا مازال يشمل الفقره المثيره
للجدل وهي رفع سن التقاعد الى 64 عاما ومن
ثم هذا النص سوف ينقل يوم غد الى مجلس
الشيوخ ليتم التصويت عليه قبل ان يذهب
لاحقا الى مجلس النواب ايضا لي التصويت
النهائي وهنا العقده التي تواجه الحكومه
والرئيس مكرون ان مجلس النواب ليس متوافقا
بشكل كامل على تمرير مشروع القانون هذا
لذلك ما يزال الرئيس محتفظ بخيار اخر وهو
ان يقوم بتمرير القانون من دون اللجوء الى
التصويت فيما يخص
الوضع الامني هناك انتشار امني كثيف جدا
في العاصمه اليوم هناك تم تصنيف هذا اليوم
على انه يوم خطير وتم رفع الجهوديه
الامنيه بشكل كبير جدا حتى ان عناصر من
الحرس الجمهوري في الشوارع العاصمه نعم من
صنف هذا اليوم يعني وزاره الوزاره او اي
جهه امنيه
قياده شرطه باريس صنفت اليوم على انه يوم
يجب رفع الجهوزيه الامنيه بشكل كبير لم
تصدر للمره الاولى اعداد او الحشد الامني
عن شرطه باريس لكن كان هناك حديث عن نحو
1700 عسكري نشر ومن بينهم قوات من الحرس
الجمهوري هؤلاء كانوا منتشرين في محيط
المواقع الحساسه لان الموكب اليوم
بالتحديد انطلق من المربع الامني في باريس
حيث تقع وزاره الخارجيه وايضا مجلس النواب
بالاضافه الى انه بالقرب من قصر الرئاسه
الفرنسيه الاليزيه كان هناك حواجز على كل
الطرق التي تؤدي الى الاليزيه وقعت قبل
قليل بعض الاشتباكات بين المتظاهرين
وعناصر الشرطه استخدمت الشرطه خلالها
كالعاده الغاز المسيل للدموع وايضا قامت
باعتقال بعض الاشخاص هناك كان في هذا
الموقع كان هناك بعض الاصابات قدمت الى
بعض الاصابات التي تم معالجتها من قبل فرق
طبيه تسير مع
المتظاهرين خلال كل هذه التظاهرات تم
تحديد المساعده لهم والان الموكب يكمل
مسيره فادي اذا امكن بايجاز خارطه
التظاهرات بالمناطق الاخرى خارج العاصمه
باريس هل يعني هناك من خارطه معينه
معظم المدن الفرنسيه شهدت تظاهرات ومعظمها
انتهت خارج باريس خصوصا في الجنوب الفرنسي
كان هناك اكبر حشد حتى الان سجل هناك 160
الف متظاهر سجل اعدادهم في مرسيليا وايضا
في مدينه نيس خرج نحو 12000 متظاهر هذه
حتى الان هي الارقام المتوفره التي
اصدرتها النقابات التي تنظم هذه التظاهرات
لكن على العموم ستاتينا لاحقا الارقام
التي تخص العاصمه شكرا لك فادي الذهب
مراسل العربيه حدثنا من باريس